yo what is it about like you and gang
members where you just you just said
track yourself to La gang members like a
[__] they love me you're gonna say I
don't know there's just La gang members
around you at all times listen I don't
know you get in where you're fitting and
I've always been a fan of this of this
music and uh at a certain point you know
like
I like having conversations with whack
100 I like having conversations with
brick baby
I do a podcast with Danny Mullen he's a
community Lord he doesn't even know what
who blueface is there's been multiple
times that I've mentioned blueface he
doesn't know who I'm talking about I
like doing that kind of content But
ultimately like the only people who are
gonna really know a lot about the music
that I'm into are pretty much gang
members or people who are equally as
fascinated by that kind of stuff as me
so yeah I don't know this is kind of
where I've ended up yeah because I'm
thinking let's see your two main
co-hosts now are whack and brick baby
right enemies can't be around each other
that's I gotta make it I gotta work
through this in time yeah and I mean
even back in the day it was like you had
Tyrell and you had you know so it's like
they couldn't be in the same place at
the same time is that a conversation
you've tried to uh you know mend a
little or is it even with trip mcinty
right I don't know with whack and uh
with whack and Brickman I think like
actually when I first started the whack
podcast there was a chance that they
were going to be able to be cool and
then it got way worse after that so at
this time probably not I do think like
based on statements that they've both
made that if they were to see each other
that it would not turn physical right at
least based on what they've said which
that to me is a big step big step
um but yeah I would love to get them on
the same page I think they would be
incredible together on camera but we're
not quite there yet I remember in the
past you had said that you would
interview six nine
I think I would now I was gonna say yeah
I don't know why but I got a feeling
it's coming you know my dedication to
the street code was so strong at a
certain time that it just kind of
blinded me and now I'm like I could do
it but at the same time it's like I
don't know six and I wanna sit down with
me when like I'm sure if he was watching
my commentary on the sick on the uh
Kodak Black six nine collab that he
probably would be like well [__] this
guy because like you know I wasn't
exactly positive about it but I think
with you and wax Dynamic like whack
would probably want to make that happen
right I would like to make it happen me
and whack talked about it he facetimed
me the other day with six nine and six
nine just started saying some random
[__] and I don't know I mean I would be
I would be cool it would be like
interesting because of the fact that I
was around six nine like in the very
very infancy of his career before he had
20 000 followers when I met him and I've
kind of seen him get to be the biggest
rapper in the game and now I guess he's
the biggest Latin artist in the game or
something he's definitely not that well
he's he's up there there's Bad Bunny
there's yeah peso pluma he's out there
but I don't I don't know I mean he's
doing his thing I don't think he's a bad
guy I just think he
you know ended up in a weird situation
do you feel like more now than ever The
Selective outrage about snitching is
like at an all-time high
I mean yeah Shadow whack 100 but black
always says selective politician right
he's the most he's the selective
politics
um yeah I mean definitely I mean because
I think I like the the [__] with the QC
guy you know and it's like
I mean a lot of guys are signing him a
lot of people yeah and I and I thought
when I saw that Story come out I'm like
God damn like are there are there
certain people that aren't going to want
to be around pee anymore just went away
nobody cared yeah it just kept it moving
yeah because he didn't tell on anybody
famous
if you snitch on Young Thug you're in
trouble if you snitch on if or if people
already kind of hate you like six nine
he told on all these real gang members
who were dying to find something no
everybody wanted to tear him down it's
almost like people wanted to tear you
down and they got that little Slither
Bingo and they were like we're that and
I think that is part of why I have
empathy for six nine now having kind of
like I mean I've lived through a few
times I guess really but like you know
just seeing how bad the pylon is and
everything and I mean what if somebody
I'm not in the streets like that if
somebody snitches it's not really my
business I really don't give a [__]
there's nothing to do with me I see Vlad
interview snitches all the time doing
all kinds of crazy leg work trying to
like explain why snitches is not big
deal or whatever in their interviews and
is what it is
um